April 1 this is Kevin from the chess
website calm and I'm excited to be
starting a new series on young chess
players who are crushing it at their age
and have all the skills to be the next
big thing in chess and definitely one
day to challenge for the world
championship today we're gonna be
looking at vincent Kaymer he is our
first because he is a 14 year old who
plays beautiful chess
he's international master from a Germany
if you're not familiar with him just
four years ago 2015 he was on the cover
of a German chess magazine and they said
he was the best talent they've seen
since last curtain you know Lasker was
German world champion for 27 years the
longest reign of a world champion in
chess so those are some big words just
last year April 2018 he played in a
tournament the Greinke chest open he was
the 99th seed in that tournament he was
13 years old there were 49 grandmasters
and four of those were over 2,700 rating
just for some context there's only 38
players in the world currently that have
over 2,700 rating there four of those
players were in this tournament last
year he was the 99th seat at 13 years
old and he won the tournament the kid is
phenomenal so we're gonna be going over
a game from that particular tournament
his opponent playing the white pieces is
Richard Report he's a 23 year old he's
currently the 18th ranked player in the
world he's a Hungarian Grandmaster he
was the Hungarian chess master in 2017
phenomenal player in his own right but
on this day last year in April 2000 18
he did run into the 13 year old Vincent
gamer who just could not be stopped in
this tournament so we'll go ahead and
get into it and watch this young master
do his work game starts out with d4 and
then d5 c4 e6 so getting into the Queens
gambit declined line Bishop g5 pinning
the down Bishop e7 just defending
against that pin III here just
solidifying the ponch
many times you'll see Knight to f3 but
instead we just see III pawn h6 for
seeing the bishop to come back here to
h4 casts on the King side rook to see
one just centralizing a little bit
Knight to d7 just protecting this may
not want to defend with his Bishop here
this also just opens up the door if he
wants to get his knight involved into
the game in the Queen's game it lying
for black many times you're not gonna be
getting the light square bishop involved
right away especially since you have
this pawn chain right here and your pawn
on e6 is blocking your light squared
bishop after the pend takes here Bishop
d3 pawn c6 solidifying the pawn chain
here on the Queen side of the board
Bishop d3 did have some options usually
sing Knight to f3 at this point but
Bishop to g3 makes sense as well rook to
e8 so there's a semi-open file that both
sides have white has it on the C file
and that's exactly where white brought
his rook here black has a semi-open file
on the e-file and that's exactly where
Kaymer brought his rook get involved
into the center of the board h3 here
does block the knight coming down to a
g4 so just preparing for his King
development he could always play Knight
to f3 castle on the King side Bishop
down to B for pinning down the Knights
here
Knight to f3 getting ready to castle and
then a nice move of Knights
efore you can see Vince it's being
extremely aggressive here and this move
threatens Knight takes on a g3 so we
know after Knight f3 Richards looking to
castle on the King side but if he
castles that would be a mistake the
knight takes here pawn recaptures and
the pawn in the center of the board
loses his only defendant from f3 and
he's gonna go down that pawn in material
so already from the get-go vincent
putting a lot of pressure on his
opponent playing the black pieces
so this attacks the bishop and Richards
forced to play Bishop to f4 before he
castles on the King side vincent
continues with c5 and then castle on the
King side decides it now that this
Bishop is not pinning down the Knights
anything goes ahead and takes that
material the pond recaptures there's no
a backward pond here on a c3 that black
can attack at some point but white does
have the bishop pair something Everage
sides going to look to have he can blow
up the center of the board really
control the board with his two bishops
black on the other hand may be looking
to clog up the center of the board
really control the board with his
Knights so with that I thought he may
play c4 now he is focused on c4 the
other option that he has is Knight to b6
any time I'm analyzing a chess position
I always love to come over to to code
chess comm if you're not familiar I'll
have a link below in the description
people always ask me what type of
software out there is that to really
improve my chess game analyze previous
games I've played and see where I've
gone wrong or maybe could have gone down
a different path what was my opponent
thinking to coach Escom will do all that
for you so if we look and you can just
import different games so I go to chess
games comm to get a lot of these older
games from previous years so I just went
and grabbed the game from here you can
easily plug that in I've already decoded
this specific position and you can see
that there's lots of options you look at
all the good moves here we already
talked about two of these Knight to b6
c4 here you can look at some of the
things for why it recommends Knight to
b6 some of the benefits here some of the
things you could pay attention to in
this position so lots of stuff going on
on this board state you can go through
the the threats the good moves the
different concepts all of that is
provided by the code chest comm and
their AI but you can also see for the
entire game where White was winning
that's where the blue line is above and
you can see the shade underneath it as
Whiteman over time that really
transitioned to black having a huge
advantage so while there are a couple
options that black has the best move
that it recommends is Knight to b6 and
that's exactly what we saw in the game
played Knight to b6 just stopping the
pawn coming up here to see for now the
knight does come to e5 here pawn f6 says
yeah you're
ahead and leave this I don't want you
attacking here comes back g4 did have
the option if he wanted to play Knight
to g6 but did come back to g4 and now we
do see c4 so preparing for his opponent
to play c4 because he did have that
option now one thing that Richards
probably looking at is if he did play
see four right away there could have
been a slew of exchanges Knight takes
here on c4 that's one of the reasons you
play that night to b6 move after the
take right here you could see the bishop
take material and then in this position
he may have looked at it and said yeah
I'm a much stronger player on paper than
Vincent is I don't want to exchange all
material you could have the Queen's come
off the board here he probably is white
has a slight advantage right now and
wants to hold on to as much material as
possible well does he know he's playing
possibly the next Bobby Fischer who
plays an amazing in game and he has to
be on his toes so after Knight to or
pawn f6 the Knights gonna fall back pawn
c4 and the bishop comes back to b1
definitely not the best spot for the
bishop right here Vincent continues to
push forward h5 kicking the Knights back
to h2 not where the knight wants to be
as well and then g5 and this is what I
really like about the 14 year old is he
is aggressive this does allow Richard to
come in and take with his Queen here on
H five pawns gonna take the bishop here
pawn to f3 forcing the knight to come
back and then queen up to h7 now did not
have the option one of the reasons we
saw this f3 move if he were to play g6
he can't perpetual check his opponent so
he didn't even have that option King to
f8 Queen h6 King to e7 so he can't draw
the game if he wanted to so after that
pawn f3 the knight comes back to d6
we see queen up here to h7 King f8 and
then h6 just can't really do much kingi
7 comes up here to g7 and then this is
another spot where there's a cup
options as far as what Black's going to
do and honestly both of them look
intriguing
we have Knight to f7 here this blocks a
lot of the threats the Queen's not going
to be coming around here anytime soon
the Knights gonna take a couple moves
for it to get involved and really attack
the King but then you also have a very
central Knight which you can use to
attack your opponent at some point King
to e6 is another option but it looks
dangerous getting your King more
centralized when your opponent still has
his queen is always dangerous now if we
come back over to to coach Escom look at
this position after Queen g7 you can see
that the computer recommends King to b6
now that does have two options here to
analyze both King e6 in Knight f7 are
viable options but you can see that it's
a better move for King to e6 some of the
reasons for that you can also look at
the alternative and see what would
happen if the plays Knight to f7 but the
preferred move is King e6 then that's
exactly what Vincent does now he doesn't
have this software as he's playing but
it's always good to see how these top
level players are analyzing these
positions so King to e6 rook here to e1
exactly what de coche s was saying rook
to e7 attacking the Queen here Queen
comes back to g4 check pawn f5 Bishop
takes here now the knight can take on f5
Queen comes up here to g6 now forcing
the King to move around a bit and after
a few checks then we have the Queen take
on f4 so if we analyze this position
right here look at the material from
from both sides white has four pawns on
the King side of the board that can
start to push forward three pawn
advantage from his opponent now one
thing the Vincent Kaymer does have is he
has an extra minor piece and minor
pieces in the endgame are extremely
important but White's gonna be looking
to push an advantage his advantage on
the King side Black's gonna try to use
all of his pieces to his best ability to
really put a strong attack on his
opponent and never give him the
opportunity to even push his pawns
now we see the bishop get involved into
the game with Bishop d6 pani for trying
to blow up the center of the board
King g8 just starting to attack the King
side the board you can also see the
threat of Bishop takes here on h3 the
pawn can't move because it's being
pinned down so that would just be a free
pawn here
the Queen's forced to come over here and
protect this pawn right here King to c7
recognizes that want the Queen's up here
if he does move the bishop he doesn't
want his King under attack that would be
an illegal move so once they get the
King out of harm's way and that's
exactly what white does as well bring
his King over here just doesn't want to
have to deal with the threat of Bishop
coming down here and the Queen just
lying down on this G file rook to f8
getting it more involved into the game
rook to e2 rook to h7 attacking the
Queen Queen comes back here to d2 just
defending here on g2 why does a complete
defense mode right now that's not what
white wants to be doing he wants to be
pushing his pawns trying to promote
putting pressure Vincent's doing exactly
what he needs to do getting all of his
major pieces involvement of the game and
threatening his opponent can come back
here to a b8 rook to e1 here we do see
the pawns taking the serve the board
Bishop back here to d7 had some options
as far as where he could go instead of
Bishop to d7 could have played rook to
f7 double up here could have also got
his Queen a little bit more involved
into the game this just incrementally
improves his position attacking some of
the center material that White has but
decides to bring his bishop back here to
d7 rook f2 says if you want to exchange
since it says not to date my friend I
need all of my material to attack you
Queen to f4 here check the King comes
over here to a pretty easy move Knight
to f3 wasn't doing too much on h2 does
need to activate that material here rook
to f8 attacking the Queen Queen comes
back here at h2 not a lot of great moves
for the Queen still wants to be involved
into the game but h2 is not where you
want your Queen to be it
envolve - now nights down a for
attacking the pawn here on a c3 it's
gonna be difficult for it to get
involved to the king side of the board
you can see right here d5 is being
stopped by the pawn on e4 which is good
for white but now he has to worry about
giving up material that backward pawn we
talked about it early on you want to
really lock in that backward pawn for
your opponent that's exactly what that
c4 move did very early on from vincit
now he can start to attack that once he
does he can easily get his knight
involved into the game and attack on the
King said or he can just continue to
gobble up the material depending on what
his opponents doing rook to e3 does
defend that material upon a6 just make
sure that if there's any attack on this
back rank you can always play King to a7
just more of a safety move for him King
to e5 here and this is tricky because
the Queen is no longer protecting the
King side of the board and then Bishop
to h3 and this is deadly because I just
don't know if he wasn't calculating
right away but pawn to h3 is not going
to work rook down here to h3 this is
going to be deadly you already see if
the Queen comes down to protect it
that's gonna be bad if instead the rook
comes over well now he can just play
rook to g3 here and this is gonna be
extremely difficult to deal with so many
different threats one the biggest
threats is the rook takes on F 3 and
then rook down here to g1 and that would
be checkmate
so from here maybe Queen to d5 says yeah
your route can come down I'll just take
your queen that's gonna be very easy for
black to continue incrementally improve
his position and still put a lot of
pressure on his opponent so knowing that
he can't take with this pond
he plays King to g1 that's a losing
proposition in the endgame here rook to
g7 just adding that double bear here
attacking this g2 Square Knight to h4
allows another defender on this g2
square
black sensing blood in the water plays
rook takes on f2 starting to gobble up
material after the king takes rook comes
down to g2 Knight takes but the Queen
takes and just has a huge attack right
here Queen down to f1 check bishop to a
g4 and this is threatening Queen over
here to g1 our d1 checkmate King to e8
it's always funny when these small
little moves that these players play you
know fifteen moves ago come back and do
exactly what they wanted to do he knew
at some point he may have to bring his
king to a7 that's exactly what happened
here
he does lose his knights here on a four
and this also protects this d1 square so
that's exactly what he wants to do but
unfortunately Queen to f2 is too much
this pawn here on c4 still doing work
can't bring his King here his rook is
gonna fall and the king is pretty safe
up here on a seven and can't get that
perpetual check that he would like to
stay in the game so at the end of the
day Richard decides to go ahead and
resign Vincent went on to win not only
this game but the tournament that really
put his name on the map here now
everywhere he goes people recognize okay
that was the that was the
thirteen-year-old that took down a
tournament with 49 at Grand Master's and
four of those being some of the top 40
players in the entire world so really
fun to analyze this game we will be
looking at another game from Vincent
Kaymer in the future just because I
really enjoy the way he plays he's all
out trying to win these games not a lot
of playing for draws which is really fun
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this game
if there's another young player could be
American could be international as well
let me know if you'd like me to analyze
some of their games and just do some
commentary on them as a player what
they've achieved in the past just to get
their name on the map for more and more
people to recognize them but thank you
guys so much for watching and I will see
you guys in the next video